this is nocturnal visit i don't know why
the o is so much bigger than all the
other letters in this word nocturnal
nocturnal they must have done that
intentionally
i just don't know why
oh oh four by three
hello car
it's pretty typical press f to turn on
your flashlight this is what i was
talking about synchronicities you know
every time i pull up somewhere and i
park my car
all of a sudden the street lamp either
turns off or starts flickering like this
this is not
an unknown
hi
i'm assuming this is my house because it
would be really weird for me to just go
up to a random house
that had the first flickering light that
i saw
and also whose car is that
hello
okay
hi
it's locked i'll look for another way
well this definitely isn't my house then
i'm not 100 sure why i'm here
but uh
okay
all right i fully expect siren head to
pop up from behind those trees
hey what's up ah trash
good um
no trash can just gonna plop it right
down the middle of the backyard
this grandma's house
is grandma not doing so good
that's not normal
it's uh usually i open a door to a house
and it's not just a black chasm into the
nothingness of the beyond i'm in
oh good yeah this is good
this is good
i have purpose for being here
this feels important to do with my life
boo
tea
[Music]
okay
well i'm gonna cut right to the quick
and i'm gonna go right for the basement
never mind this door heads to the
basement how did i know that
i don't know i'm a little bit of an
expert when it comes to horror games
doesn't seem edible don't insult
grandma's cooking like that
you don't know what she's been
some leftovers good great
great great great
drippy well so far so normal no body
no body parts in the fridge it is weird
that there are bags of trash also in the
fridge
and a book
i can't tell what that is and a spider
web
and a garbage can they do have one and
oh that's a lid i thought that was like
a film reel or something
oh this place is such a mess
yeah i know
that's why i'm here i'm assuming this is
like
house flipper but scary
house flipper also was a little bit
scary this door leads to the garage okay
[Music]
all right
perfectly normal thing when you walk
into a house and expect there to be
people alive
i don't trust that
okay
[Music]
no comment on that
hello no
okay i could either take a quick nap or
i could run out the front door screaming
the last thing that i would do in this
scenario is go up into the attic
that would be absolutely the not thing
that i would do
[Music]
okay let's do that let's do that thing
that i don't want to do
we
hi
oh yeah this is good
[Music]
you fell i was about to talk about you
now you were weirdly perched right there
and looked important
all right sure
key it is garage key obtained great
i'm assuming that i don't need to turn
around and see anything spooky behind me
sure sure sure right am i gonna get a
spooky fax
no okay all right
okay
uh-huh only minorly broke my legs there
let's go to the garage let's go to the
garage let's go to the garage
let's not go to the garage let's go to
not to the garage let's go anywhere but
the garage hey who's in the garage
another car
oh
good
i bet there's nothing behind me
i was right
i'm a genius my predictive skills are
just that good
okay
all right cool okay
grandma
grandma grandma grandma grima grama
grama
oh
i guess i didn't need a key after all
hey
swirling my asthma of red chaos
oh
well now that i've called you out by
your true name swirling my asthma of red
chaos
you have to obey me
stop being scary this instant or else
i'll have to come down there and scream
in your face
and you wouldn't want that oh that's an
ominous horse
a squonkiest horse i ever did see
all right good yeah you better stop
saved up all squeaking for this one
moment it really really blew its squeak
load hey ah ah phone the house just
seems abandoned overall nothing has
happened about 10 minutes in and i'm
starting to feel a bit overwhelmed i
really don't like the environment in
this place i've heard several weird
noises and i feel like i'm being watched
getting in this place was a complete
mistake
something is definitely stalking me the
door is locked and i got no way of
getting out i'm screwed something's
coming to the basement
who's calling the phone from upstairs is
ringing well that's great
that's great grandma i'll get that one
i'm not allowed to answer the phone on
account of what happened last time
all right fine
coming as if you could hear me through
the phone
coming
hello
ah all the way upstairs right coming
to the la
what's the opposite of toodle-oo if
toot-a-loo was a goodbye
hello
honda lundo
toppled
[Applause]
[Music]
uh behind me
there was nothing again looks like my
job's done here
time to go home
did the back door just open
freedom
i'm free
i'm getting out of here
hey oh hey
hey neighbor is that the hash slinging
slasher
hi oh no hey whoa don't kill me oh don't
jump out of me
[Music]
[Applause]
way too close way too close
way too close
whoa
whoa i love that that was good very
spooky i mean typical haunted house
exploration thing but did it really well
i love these kind of short horror games
you know i really do it's a it's a good
start for anyone that like wants to dip
their toes into like making games and
i'm not saying that like this game is
just made by a complete amateur but it's
just like oh it's such cool bite-sized
experiences that allow you to experiment
with like a game engine and get started
in it and just have fun with it so great
still don't know why the o was bigger
but good game like that
i like that a lot
[Music]
you